donald trumps residenz murray lago in
palm beach florida gekauft hatte sie
1985 für rund zehn millionen dollar der
aktuelle wert wird 16 mal so hoch
geschätzt vom boden aus ist kaum etwas
zu sehen denn das gelände wird streng
abgeschirmt deshalb haben wir ein
helikopter gemietet und schauen uns das
ganze einmal aus der luft an marie lago
ist nicht nur donald trumps bevorzugter
wohnsitz außerhalb washingtons sondern
auch ein exklusiver privatclub 100.000
dollar jahresgebühr kostet die
mitgliedschaft klos 14.000 dollar an
weiteren abgaben dafür kann man dann das
privileg genießen in der nähe des
amtierenden präsidenten zu dinieren oder
möglicherweise bald des ex-präsidenten
sollte donald trump die wahl verlieren
hier gibt es auch noch gewesen bisher
ist diese anlage ein privates
luftangriff deshalb steuervorteile
sollte daran kann hier einzeln wieder
als erwartet
dann müsste er auch mehr steuern zahlen
das natürlich hier im kerker gehe es
gerade die frage wann donnerstag hier
einziehen wird teilweise bereits seit
januar oder ersten vier ja dass der
amerikanischen entscheidet doch donald
trumps winter white house ist auch mal
strategisch von bedeutung in der nähe
zeigen die republikaner dauerpräsenz auf
einer autobahnbrücke werben um jede
stimme
denn wenn donald trump am beach gewinnt
könnte das die wahl auch anderswo
beeinflussen
alles hängt vom pan beach county ab das
ist sozusagen ground zero sowie bauern
quält wird ganz florida und die gesamte
nation und wenn das nicht klappt werden
die republikaner hier donald trump wohl
noch öfter zu sehen bekommen als bisher
denn im fall einer wahlniederlage will
er seinen hauptwohnsitz von new york
hierher verlegen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren